good evening I'm Jack Luxenberg it's my
privilege to serve temple Bethenny as
its rabbi and it's my privilege and my
pleasure to welcome you this evening
to an event which our congregation is
honored to host an event which is of
significance not only to our own Jewish
community but to the Jewish people in
its entirety I'd like to take a moment
before we begin to thank those persons
and organizations that have made this
evening possible for us I'd like to
thank the primary sponsor of this
evening the anti-defamation league and
say that it was a pleasure to work with
its regional director David Friedman and
helping to make this evening possible we
worked in association with a generation
after and it's president ester finder
here at Temple Bethany we are grateful
to our executive director Janice
Rosenblatt and her staff for seeing to
the many administrative details
associated with this evenings
presentation and we are pleased to be
joined in sponsorship by the religious
Action Center of Reform Judaism by
Benedict congregation and of course
temple Bethany its officers or of
directors and its membership are pleased
to welcome all of you this evening I'd
like to also make a special
acknowledgement of the participation and
the support of this event by mr. David
porting a member of Temple Bethany a
friend of the author Edwin black whose
generosity has supported many aspects of
this evenings program
louder please okay I'll do my best okay
okay thank you I'm gonna have it I'm
gonna have the mic adjusted and for just
a moment
I'd like to say something about the
schedule for this evening we are going
to be privileged to hear from the author
of this important new book IBM in the
Holocaust mr. Edwin black following mr.
blacks remarks we will hear comments and
reflection and by mr. William Seltzer
and dr. Robert wolf their introductions
will precede their remarks we will have
an opportunity for questions and answers
and following the conclusion of the
program everyone is invited to a simple
reception that will be held in the lobby
area just outside the doors of the
sanctuary where we may meet and greet
each other speak personally with the
author and those who wish may acquire
copies of the book IBM and the Holocaust
the book which Edwin black has written
is more than a historical record it is
more than an accounting of a distasteful
and disturbing episode in corporate
Jewish history it is in my estimation of
warning a relevant warning to those of
us who live in the 21st century where
the possibilities and potentials of
technology are both wondrous and
frightening is a book that tells us that
we must beware of technology that is
unfettered by his profound sense of
morality and that we should be wary of a
corporate mentality which is not
governed by conscience Edwin black is
the author of the best-selling book the
transfer agreement the dramatic story of
the pact between the third rice and
Jewish Palestine which won the Carl
Sandburg award for nonfiction in 1984
and of format see an apocalyptic y2k
techno thriller which was published in
1999 his newest book IBM in the
Holocaust the strategic alliance between
Nazi Germany and America's most powerful
corporation has recently been published
by crown publishers between 1986 and
1988 Edwin black syndicated column the
cutting edge was published by newspapers
in 50 cities across the United States
and Canada during this period it
received three nominations for the
Pulitzer Prize and was noted for
breaking stories on the skinheads the
Aryan Brotherhood the black Hebrews and
Israeli religious strife among others in
1987 to 88 the column originated from
Jerusalem where Edwin black was based as
a foreign correspondent
and during his time there mr. black
landed exclusive interviews with Prime
Minister Yitzhak Shamir and Egyptian
ambassador Muhammad ba Sunni further he
was the only non Israeli print
journalist to accompany Shimon Peres on
his surprise summit in Cairo in February
of 1987 for the column mr. black also
accompanied the South Lebanese army on
patrol in Lebanon anti-defamation
leaders during their Pollard crisis
mission to Jerusalem and the Jerusalem
bomb squad during an outbreak of terror
bombings as a journalist Edwin black has
written primarily investigative articles
for publications as diverse as
Businessweek Los Angeles Times Chicago
Tribune Sunday magazine Redbook and
Mademoiselle among others he has also
been editor and publisher of a number of
award-winning publications including
Chicago Monthly and great American pace
his passion his conviction and his
commitment has brought to light this
extraordinary episode this extraordinary
insight unto the house of the Holocaust
we all people of conscience will be
forever in his debt mr. Edwin black
can people hear me okay thank you all
very much for coming I know we had very
short notice as you evolve have heard
not only the book but this meeting was
embargoed and but I'm happy you all did
come out I have my own thanks to say
before I explain to you what has
happened with this book first of all I
need to thank our host Jack Luxembourg
rabbi Luxembourg is when I first met him
displayed an incredible knowledge of the
period and he had a great number of
personal questions about my motivation
about my background about my
understanding and only then did he want
to go on to the facts I was very very
impressed with his insights and I just
want to say thank you very very much
I'd also like to thank Dave porty who
was a good friend of the family and who
has helped bring this about Dave is
right here and there are a number of
people in this audience who worked with
me month in month out to help bring this
book to fruition I'm sure you've heard
that there were a hundred people in
seven countries some of those hundred
are here right now I'd like to introduce
a few of them if I could because they
are here first of all I'd like to
introduce Fred T Berger former analyst
for the Nuremberg war crimes office and
Fred was one of them one of my
researchers and he helped give us a
great deal of not only contemporary
insight but he had this incredible mind
to go through all the files tediously
until he found just a perfect ones Fred
thank you very much
I'd like to thank David Coletti David
Coletti you may have heard that we
sometimes worked in two shifts we'd
start 8 o'clock in the morning and end
up at 2 o'clock at night well the guy
who was working 2 o'clock at night
because David we'd all go to sleep and
we'd find out what David was had David
had done in the morning in terms of
finding documents making Xeroxes and
yellow lining things so did David is
though our volunteer in in chief and I
want to thank him he's still
volunteering he's still working and he's
were forever in his death thank you very
much David David
we had a great footnoting team there
were actually two teams of people there
were people working on the manuscript
and people whose job it was to tear
apart the manuscript and or prove it
with physical documentation and so we
would have like Oh 5 or 6 people at a
time required to have consensus that we
had proved our case and they were they
were persnickety they were here they
were here splitting they were
adversarial and one of them is Sally
murex she was here and she was one of
those who specialized in certain areas
like on certain parts of the Nazi
hierarchy I like to say Sally thank you
very much
and I don't see anyone else from the
team other than the guy who headed up
he's left of course the guy who headed
up the team I described in the book as
the best archivist and historian I had
met in many a year and that's actually
an understatement because Nils was
involved knows Cortez was involved in it
in virtually every comma and every
footnote in the book and it was one of
those who would just come in after the
fact after everybody had had had done
their work and said now you've got
you've got to understand this and you've
got to understand that he would somehow
find things that no one else has found
Nils worked in Washington in New York he
worked at the corporate archives in
Delaware he worked in London at the
public record office I sent him to
Berlin on no that's it right okay so
he's across the Atlantic Ocean a couple
times for us and he is here and believe
you me his fingerprints are all over
this book thank you
and a great and a great translator now
in addition to the people who worked in
my basement and who worked in far-flung
archives there were a number of people
who were in who were intellectual
Godfather's to this work people without
whom there would be no compass there
would be no no ability to start off one
of them two of them are here tonight one
of them is bill Seltzer and William
Seltzer at from Fordham University is
the former director of the UN statistics
office and he happens to be the world's
most accomplished expert on the subject
of punch cards used in census to
persecute minorities during the
Holocaust and we ran into each other a
couple of months ago and he had a
tremendous technical expertise about
these cards not something that a person
like I just looking at them or any
historian looking at them could not
quite grasp he had the mechanical
understanding and he had done a lot of
independent research too had criss
crossed my own and we came to and we
came together and we just met a couple
of days ago at CNN so I'd like to
introduce and say thank you to Bill
I'm gonna save my further remarks on Bob
Bob wolf for his introduction but you
need to understand something there are
thousands of experts and tens of
thousands of people who think they're
experts on the Holocaust and world war
two I think most of them who know what
they're talking about would agree that
the number one expert on the
documentation is seated in the front row
here this is Robert wolf and I'll say
more about him later but you must
understand when people go into the
National Archives to look at documents
they're looking at his fingerprint
smudges from decades ago this man knows
them all he was a constant
uncompromising authority in his field
bless you very much and his beautiful
wife who was also translating for me
yeah I'm longing to say two more quick
things I want to thank the
anti-defamation league and I want to
thank in especially David Friedman who
helped organize this event and I want to
thank my wife and my my wife and
daughter who stood with me and missed me
all all those nights for a year they
worked in 17 hours a day in the basement
and afters anybody else did I missed of
course
Meredith Esther Esther fender from
generation after which is one of the
sponsors there was so many so many
people that gave me spiritual support
and I needed that constantly because it
was such a dark staircase and I fumbled
so so many times and Esther fender is
one of the most outstanding people in
our community when it comes to these
issues
she is selfless she is dedicated she's
connected and she helped me every step
along the way Esther thank you very much
I tell you in a community like ours to
find someone as a as a political and
devoted as this person is a rare rare
thing thank you very much
so now we're going to talk about IBM and
the and the Holocaust when I talk about
IBM in the Holocaust I talk about a
chapter of history that I encountered
first in 1993 at the Holocaust Museum
here in Washington when I was standing
with my parents both of whom are Polish
survivors some of you know the story
that my mom was in was on her way to
Treblinka in the boxcar and her mother
pushed her out and she was buried in a
mass grave and her leg was sticking out
of the snow when my father who had
walked away from a shoots and plots from
a shooting place just happened upon her
saw her leg sticking out pulled her out
that's how they met and they lived for
two years in the woods and that's why
I'm here not by accident so
when I saw this machine I saw two words
that made no sense
IBM Holocaust I could those two words
did not compute and then I began to
understand we have examined every aspect
of the genocide 'el activity we have
explored the military intelligence we
have tracked the assets we have
uncovered the diplomatic cables but the
one area we have not covered or explored
or investigated is information
technology and no one even knew to do
this until recently because now we're in
the computer age and so I decided that I
would find out just how far the
solutions company went in helping the
Nazis the machine that was in the
Holocaust Museum said only that it
worked on census but I know the IBM mind
set and their mindset is to anticipate
your clients needs know your customer
and anticipate their needs and so I
assembled a team slowly difficult of
some 100 researchers translators
historians volunteers in seven countries
working in 50 archives and we
accumulated some 20,000 documents a few
of which I have brought with me here
today when I travel
I travel with documents and a picture
emerged and that picture is that IBM and
its president Thomas J Watson
established and engineered a dynamic
strategic business alliance with Nazi
Germany from the very first moment in
1933 right through the war and this
Business Alliance does technological
ions endowed Adolf Hitler with the
ability to accelerate and to automate
every aspect of Jewish persecution from
the identification to the social
expulsion to the confiscation to the
ghettoization to the deportation and yes
to the extermination
I'll go through a few things
iBM has said that it severed all
relations with its German subsidiary
when the war broke out in 1939 here's a
copy of the New York Times right after
the invasion of Poland September 39 this
is the September 13th edition three
million Jews are going to be removed
immediately say the Nazis from Poland
and they wonder how can this be done
without their physical extermination
anyone will be able to examine these
later at the same time on September 9th
the German managers of IBM write a
Presta letter to Thomas J Watson
directly who personally supervise to
German subsidiary hour-to-hour during
the entire pre-war period he was in
Germany two and three times a year and
they say you will understand that under
today's conditions a certain need has
arisen for such machines that we do not
build yet in Germany they wanted the
high-speed all-powerful alphabetizes
and then they say and this offer which
you made to us to take these machines
this will be undoubtedly greatly
appreciated in many and especially
responsible circles and those
alphabetize errs were approved a few
days letter a few days later not in any
letter but in a telephone conversation
to the Swiss office which was relayed to
the Berlin office and it says if
agreement has been expressed to our
keeping the machines I had asked for
until further notice on the basis of a
proposition and this information was
transmitted by the European general
manager mr. shott from mr. Watson and
here are the serial numbers here are the
model numbers of the first alphabetizing
machines that came in to Nazi Germany
thanks to Thomas J Watson at just when
the newspapers were reporting that
Poland had been invaded and that three
million Jews were about to be
exterminated exterminated now we do not
ask mr. Watson or IBM to be aware of
military intelligence we do not ask them
to be aware of diplomatic cables but we
assume that what's in the New York Times
what's on the radio in the newsreel is
something that they would be aware of
and I constantly quote two New York
Times because that is where they lived
if they would have lived in Boston I
would have courted the Boston Globe and
as is known the Jews at that time just a
few just a few months later were
congregated at railroad depots in
well-known documents which are now being
looked at again today in a different
light in a continuous census was taken
of them and that this was called the
final goal the end ziyal and this was
the a step toward what they considered
to be but did not verbalize if the final
solution
now let's look at some more some more
documents here are some contracts I want
everyone to see this contract it's with
the Dutch administrator of Watson's
subsidiary in Holland except the
contract is not with the Holland
subsidiary the contract is not with the
German subsidiary the contract is with
International Business Machines
Corporation in New York this is an
example on one of the documents that mr.
Robert wolf founded about the first five
minutes of this task there right in the
National Archives there's dozens of
these and these of course are dated in
1942 now what's interesting is that
after this invasion of Poland that I
spoke about where these outfit izing
machines went in Watson then established
a special German subsidiary in occupied
Poland to service the occupying forces
maintained a printing planting plant at
six ride marceca street directly across
the street from the Warsaw Ghetto
printed up 20 million punch cards and
the leading customer was the railroads
this is not just a book about
identification this is not just a book
about census the railroads ran on punch
cards in fact this is not even a book
about the German subsidiary we're
talking about all the subsidiaries
because the documentation shows that IBM
rushed to put in new subsidiaries in
cadence with the Nazi takeover of Europe
right after Poland is invaded he puts in
a German subsidiary in occupied Poland
just before Holland is invaded he rushes
a special Dutch subsidiary in all
reporting directly to New York now I
know that I know that IBM will say that
it lost control of its subsidiary at
some point it had no control over there
these people after the
war started October 9th 1941 to Thomas J
Watson European general manager mr. leer
writes a letter and in this letter he's
in Berlin reporting directly to New York
and he says I'm the occasion of my visit
to Berlin I also said a few pending
matters such as the machines blocked in
Poland and the Romanian census in other
words the year the European general
manager is in Berlin writing back to New
York on October 9th 1941 unblocking
machines stuck in war-torn Poland and
moving them into Romania we're in the
middle of one of the most heinous and
bloody exterminations of the war and the
very next day he sends a detailed
explanation to the rest of the senior
staff and he tells them machines blocked
in Poland Romanian census that he
intervened with mr. woods the u.s.
commercial attache to move these
seventeen machines blocked in Poland
they also got in touch with the foreign
currency Commission of Germany called
The Da Vida Stella foreign currency
office and various German authorities
quote as regards to census intervention
and especially in view of the fact that
neither we nor dae-ho MOG that's the
name of the German subsidiary were able
to get a precise information on just
what they need he assigned a German
employee to go to Romania from Berlin
and also a member of the German
Statistical Office from Berlin to go to
Romania
and the Romanian operation was not an
operation of the German subsidiary it
was directly under the control and
profit center of the New York office and
as is known there were horrific
brutalities in Romania and the war crime
records show that many of the
intelligence officers relied upon their
liaisons in the Census and statistical
offices to get this information you know
it's very interesting but here's a
letter from Bell from Watson belch the
Belgian subsidiary it's from night it's
Jeff actually in 1939 iBM is at the
height of organizing the Japanese
aircraft industry prior to Pearl Harbor
that's somebody else's book and he says
it's none of our business to judge the
reasons why an American corporation
should or would help reform government
we as IBM men are interested only in the
technical side of the application of our
machines
here's a letter 1945 right after the war
July 4th first a letter to mr. Watson
and the guy says remember me I ran your
your check office he's just giving a
resume of everything so you know and we
moved right after the war began with the
United States that's in December 41 we
moved all the money rentals to IBM
Geneva and we had an exchange rate it
was all stored on a block to count'em
Prague and then he says in 1942 he met
with mr. Chauncey that's IBM that that's
Watson's personal emissary an attorney
with ayat with IBM and we met him in
while he was visiting Berlin and he made
an agreement that we in the Czech
division could take German machines made
by this german subsidiary called de home
AG and sell them as though they were
ours with our name plate in other words
make an export arrange or arrangement so
what did it all look like well there are
many punch cards none of them were
standard I know they'd like to say what
we just didn't know but each one of
these punch cards was custom made and
specifically designed for the
application because of slave labor card
and as you can see it's like any other
mock-up that you would do and this one
has French French and Dutch in Hungarian
and occupied by Allah stuck and they of
course had to figure out exactly what
cut what hole would be punched in what
column in what row here's another one
for various types of occupational
activity whether you were a bricklayer
or a lumbermen and consequently when the
extermination by labor program was in
progress they could put all these cards
together and locate how many individuals
of any stripe or from any background
whether they were Jews or or or
of war or gypsies or just jehovah's
witnesses who these people were what
skills they had and so when they said we
need 27 watchmakers in Auschwitz and to
move them to sachsen housing as they
sometimes did that's a real number they
could find them by by setting a few
dials and this is what some of them
looked like and by the way these
mock-ups all board the distinctive logo
type of IBM subsidiary they're dejó MOG
Darja Hollerith machine and gazelle
shaft and then this is a typical card
but by no means a common card they all
looked a little bit different this is
for the race office of the SS this is
another SS card once again they have the
insignia of the company up at the top
and some of these cards had 40 columns
and some had 80 columns and some had
boxes they all looked very very
different and you didn't need a punch
card tongue to take this this is why
people have not been able to understand
what this happens for 60 years this was
a typical prisoner card it's a piece of
paper there's a hundred and thirty
thousand of these at the Bundys our
chief and the vice president of the
Bundys our chief told me there's nothing
in this in these piece of paper has
anything to do with punch cards so we
took a magnifying glass and we see here
Hollerith Vermin math which is the
notation from the Hollerith company and
down here it says for schlissel t' which
means key did and here it says la carte
de proofed which means verified by
another punch card machine and it's
operator six and so what starts as a
piece of paper ends up being punched in
this particular man lost his name he's
only a number he's arrested by [ __ ]
that's the Criminal Police which is - he
goes to Dachau which is three and he was
real and he was and I believe he was a a
work helper and all of his information
can be punched into various numbers
squared so let's compare this to the
camp codes
this document was one of the most
important documents it's in the National
Archives was found by nils cordis I was
shaking when he found it
Dachau three well let's just go through
it Gestapo is the one kripo is - what
type of inmates do we have Jehovah's
Witnesses a - of homosexuals of three a
communist Spaniard is a six udin 8 June
8th where are the camps uh sure it's one
book and odd to Dachau three that's all
three mud house in seven ravines brook
Tenon's what is the status of the the
quote departure 1 + + + + 1 uber stolen
transferred to cast or band three
natural causes whatever natural causes
of death are in a concentration camp
executions formerly ordered execution
for fright for freighted which is
suicide 5 escape - 7 & 6
Xander behind lunk special handling
extermination 6 an engineer from IBM got
together with a Nazi client and figured
out Santa Bronwyn was 6
aash wits 30,000 cards Hollerith are
fast we're not sure where these were
actually stamped whether the papers were
moved out to another camper to an
off-site location even the punishment
was some was coated just like today we
code punishment we can keep records of
the type of punishment prisoners have
there's a document I've offered a
thousand dollars to anyone who who can
find this is a document that's listed in
the National Archives that isn't in the
National Archives in fact 90% of the
documents I saw in the National Archives
are not listed in the National Archives
are not found in the National Archives
this is a purport list of documents from
France from the Justice Department
it says political affairs and France
transmitted copies of letter addressed
to mr. Pete Taylor of the International
Business Machines and written by a
shannon who is one of the Belgian
officials which indicates that mr. t HJ
Watson approved mr. Rochelle's policy of
crap of collaboration with Germany it
shows it's in four different folders
it's missing from all four folders
everything you could do with a computer
today you could do back then with a
Hollerith machine but slower when Hitler
embarked upon his enterprise of Jewish
destruction it was so massive and
undertaking that had called for the
resources of a computer but there was no
computer
there was the Hollerith punch card
system and this punch card system
endowed the Hitler regime with the
ability to automate
and data process it has demonstrated to
us who studied the documentation and
perhaps to you if you will read the book
that the information age was not born in
Silicon Valley but in Berlin in 1933 I
don't do any moralizing in this book
there are plenty of rabbis around cool
judge honey view will judge each in your
own heart in your own way but if there
is a message to this book it is that the
slogan never again will not just be a
catchphrase for the Holocaust but a
mantra for executives everywhere that
their technology their asses their
corporate muscle shall never again be
used to afflict innocent civilians thank
you and I'll take questions
excuse me I'm not going to take
questions you're going to hear from the
esteemed William Seltzer thank you you
have heard Edwin of remarked upon mr.
Seltzer's extraordinarily relevant
expertise in the tech not on the
keypunch technology you should know that
mr. Seltzer in addition to this area of
scholarship is today a senior research
scholar at Fordham University before
that he served the United Nations as a
senior advisor to the Under Secretary
General and the Department for economic
and social information and policy
analysis he served as the director of
the United Nations statistical division
in a prescient confluence of interest
and professional obligation mr. seltzer
was the organizer of a conference on
using data and quantitative analysis to
obtain evidence for international
criminal tribunals and very recently
using both his academic and his
historical and technical expertise mr.
seltzer served as a consultant to the
were crimes tribunal reviewing the
tragic events in Rwanda mr. seltzer
thank you
I am honored to be invited to say a few
words tonight about edwin's black's
detailed and well-documented account of
the involvement of IBM and its president
Thomas J Watson in the Holocaust and
because I'm trying to keep within the
limits that by Sundberg said I'm gonna
read from my remarks rather than speak
extemporaneously there is so much to be
said
edwin has said some of it this evening
and the book of course says far more I
can speak for itself rather than talk
directly about the book I would I
thought I would try to deal with a few
of the ways the book has been
misunderstood or misconstrued since it
was published and then conclude with a
few words about the implications of this
book for the future first it is said by
IBM and others that this is old news so
much of it is but not all of it
however what was known was known only by
a few and only in fragments Edwin black
has gathered together and assembled the
scattered forgotten and sometimes lost
pieces of a jigsaw puzzle to reveal a
picture that will not be so easily
forgotten in the future and I think we
all owe him a debt of gratitude for that
second we are told as as edwin has said
we are told that IBM lost control of its
German subsidiary dialogue after the war
began in part that depends on what you
mean by war the war against the Jews
began rather early
but even after Germany invaded Poland in
1939 IBM was still very much in control
it provided new
mint and it coordinated the transfer of
equipment from occupied Poland to
Romania
well one may ask what did IBM and Watson
know and when did they know it the book
makes several things clear about the IBM
the involvement of IBM in daija MOG
operations first IBM and Watson went to
considerable efforts to conceal both
from the German and the American
authorities the degree to which diem
agreement an IBM subsidiary in spirit if
not in law from 1933 through 1945 second
Watson's
Watson's management style tended to
involve him deeply in the activities of
his subsidiaries he wasn't one of these
very high-level managers he was down
there knowing what was what was going on
third after the US and Germany entered a
state of war in 1941 conservators were
appointed to run its German subsidiary
an arrangement that protected its
operations and profits fourth even
before the war in Europe ended IBM and
Watson quickly began to retake control
of the Hollerith equipment used by the
Nazis as IBM property and gather up the
substantial profits generated by day
amok from its Holocaust and other
wartime activities in short the claim
that IBM lost control of day among
during the war seems strained at best I
have also read this past week that what
IBM did was no different than what other
companies such as Ford Motor Company did
in trading with Germany this is just not
the case punch-card technology then new
to Germany was quickly embraced by Nazi
leadership and German technocrats
both the newness of this technology and
its very nature dependent upon the
provision of goods that's the least
equipment itself and the millions of
punch cards and a continued flow of
specialized technical services by daija
mark staff in this respect punch card
technology differed in a fundamental way
from other goods provided by provided to
access countries by American companies
directly or through their former
subsidiaries cars and typewriters once
in German hands could be used without
further support from the original
manufacturer in Nazi controlled Europe
between 1933 and 1945 users of punch
card technology dependent upon the
on-site expertise of de la Marck staff
and that of other IBM's European
subsidiaries to service the machines to
design the punch cards needed for each
new application and to wire the sorters
tabulators and alphabetizes used to
generate any kind of output whether a
simple statistical table a complex cross
tabulation or a list of names and
related information and again that
expertise was not remote it was on-site
where the machines were wherever the
machines were the experts had to be the
technical staff from the of the European
subsidiaries fourth I have heard it said
that the books thesis is that IBM and
punch card technology caused the
Holocaust and again this is not the case
ed wooden black makes clear in the books
introduction on page 11 if you want to
check it out that it would be wrong to
think that IBM technology caused the
Holocaust the Holocaust itself did not
originate from punch card technology the
Nazis were certainly able to kill many
Jews Gypsies and other targeted
populations without it
rather as black argues the major
contribution of punch-card technology
was its impact on the speed and can
contain ental scope of the Holocaust
operations punch-card technology as
implemented by IBM made genocide
efficient and the final solution a
realizable goal what are the main
lessons of this book and blacks research
for the future I would highlight two as
central and here I find myself fun
simply echoing what rabbi Luxembourg and
Edwin black has have already said but
let me restate them in my my words first
although new and powerful technologies
may be morally neutral what we do with
them is not it may be recalled but at
the time punch-card technology was at
the cutting edge of what we now refer to
as information processing its power to
do good was viewed as virtually without
limit while few were alerted to
potential misuses
the public corporate executives public
or private sector bureaucrats and
scientists all need to be active in
identifying potential misuses of new
technologies and scientific discoveries
and in preventing promoting effective
safeguards second based on my own
research I have concluded that those
statisticians and demographers
associated with population data
collection systems that assisted in
human rights abuses seemed to be so
motivated by professional zeal or
bureaucratic agendas that they were
blind to the ethical implications of
their work similarly
Watson and his colleagues seemed so
proud of their technology and so caught
up in their corporate goals that they
also ignored the profound evils they
were furthering
the common theme here is that the
ethical dimensions of our activities
should never be forgotten thank you
as you may have noted from Edwin's
earlier remarks dr. Robert wolf of the
National Archives an expert on captured
German records war crime trial records
and World War two holds a special place
in the development and the genesis of
the book IBM in the Holocaust and
therefore mr. black has asked for the
opportunity to say a few special words
about dr. Robert Walton ladies and
gentlemen it's my honor and privilege
and personal satisfaction to introduce
Robert wolf he has described simply as
the chief documentarian of the National
Archives on Nazi documents and kept and
captured records but he is more than
that he has been the bedrock of research
for hundreds of historians around the
world who for years would come to the
National Archives and impose upon his
considerable knowledge of where
everything is hidden you know when you
when you come to the archives you have
to ask to be let around because the
archivist understands what you don't
understand he knows where the secrets
are he knows where the documents are and
they have this incredible logical mind
you walk in the door with all sorts of
ideas breaking in your head and suddenly
in a moment he says well let's look here
and out comes an IBM contract he's been
honored in Germany for his contributions
to this documentation he is known
worldwide he's currently a member of the
interagency working group which is
involved in the further freeing up of
all documents Bob is struggling now that
all these documents should be
declassified and it's my privilege to
introduced a man whose integrity and
whose intellect and whose wisdom and
experience I have tapped but more
importantly the world has tapped for
decades Robert wolf I conveniently
mislaid my resume that I was asked to
present tonight because well first of
all my wife figures I'm vain enough not
to hear all of this praise but secondly
I want you to pay attention now I want
to convince you by what I say and not by
Who I am it doesn't make a bit of
difference if my arguments are cogent
then that's all that is important now
mr. Edwin black when as a young man he's
still a young man but as a young man
years ago thirty years ago maybe that
much he came to the archives he was
talking about something called the
transfer agreement now here I was
sitting on all of this Nazi material far
too much for any archivist
to know what he has until somebody
triggers it so I learned about the
transfer agreement helping Edwin black
do his research a smart archivist always
learns from his researchers he begins by
leading them so years later Here I am in
retirement merely a volunteer at the
National Archives if something
interesting comes up where I'm needed or
whether they can't find the records and
I probably mislaid them years ago they
can call me up and then there is this
fellow Edwin black yeah I had heard of
him and he comes with something else
that I had never perceived I'm not
technologically minded anyway but here
again he
something that had been broached but
never really approached in the broad
sense that I knew he insisted on doing
it look at everything you want snore
everything and so and this you have to
understand before I give you my judgment
on the book particularly the context of
his book I agreed to assist him and in
fact I and my wife is a translator
traveled with him to Germany for
expenses no fees and that's important
because in other words I haven't been
bought we hear a lot in Washington about
people's opinions being bought mine
doesn't get bought and I continued for
the last year or two whenever he needed
some counsel or advice to accept calls
from him sometimes a little later in the
evening than an old man likes but of
course it was intriguing to me I had
this fund of useless knowledge that
somebody finally wanted so it revives
the spirits of uses of the feeling of
usefulness that most of us after we
retire don't have right I am now going
to read what I have to say about this
book in the context of what happened
because these are complex matters and I
like to be precise normally I like to
talk freely my wife says I do better
when I do that and when when I mumble
over a script but I'm going to mumble
over this script the indifference of
today's international global
conglomerate conglomerate's to national
interests let alone moral considerations
was foreshadowed more than a
half-century ago by
IBM's collaboration with Hitler's Reich
mainly because of Thomas J Watson
pursuit of total world market share the
sorted primary records documenting this
are marshaled in Edwin blacks IBM and
the whole Kahala cost a doubly timely
book because it not only discloses this
conflict of international economic with
national interests but also the
potential curse blessings aside of data
processing technology most of these
primary sources had been sitting there
worldwide neglected for more than 50
years until black assemble them into
this comprehensive in detailed account
since Herman Hollerith developed his
punch card system at the turn of the
20th century most major governments and
industries have used it for various
useful and benevolent purposes for
example the United States for its
decennial census we're still talking
about whether the census is accurate or
not the way it is done but at least the
data is still being processed by
technology some say that our voting
processes are also being processed by
modern technology but they were using
the old punch cards that were obsolete
by 1960 in Germany its component States
used Hollerith cards to manage among
others things their tax systems
including Church taxes German tax payers
earmarked their payments which provided
the revenue to be allocated to their own
denominations for maintenance of
churches significant synagogues
parochial schools and subsidiary
eleemosynary institutions consequently
the tax rules registered the affiliation
of the individual taxpayer
although alien to Americans separation
of church and state this practice and
even the parallel compilations
of the Reich genealogical office the
Raisa penomet
were useful and harmless in the hands of
Aymara public officials already during
the First World War Watson's German
subsidiary had been put under an enemy
property administrator but was restored
to his control after the 1918 armistice
for which he ostentatiously proclaimed
his gratitude this contributed to his
expectation of similar treatment when
America entered the Second World War
like many domestic German monopolists he
exploited the Great Inflation of the
early 1920s to buy out most of his
German competitors at rock-bottom costs
after 1933 concerned that Nazi
chauvinism might lead to nationalization
of foreign Holdings he successfully
flattered Hitler and the Nazis on their
advent to power as you will read in the
book even got a medal which then he
decided reluctantly to return after
Chris Tona Third Reich central regional
and local governments including the
foreign ministry all Nazi Party central
offices and branches including its brown
and black shirted formations the SA and
SS and it supervised and affiliated
organizations the parties the three
branches of the German armed forces
industry agriculture and transportation
all made assiduous use of the van most
modern technology ibm's Hollerith
machines and punch cards for
administration production and
distribution directly or indirectly
connected to the Nazi rise to power and
war effort even when IBM New York lost
day-to-day control of day home OGG IBM's
branch in nazi germany watson as head of
IBM and Hermann befell injure the Third
Reich's appointed trustee for the day
ohmic enemy property demonstrated a
reciprocal concern for retention of
IBM's worldwide near monopoly
of data processing at the expense of
this respective second world war efforts
of both the Allies and the Third Reich
IBM and the Holocaust documents Watson's
indifference the Nazi violation of civil
and human rights and his tacit condoning
of indirect trading with the enemy after
Hitler's declaration of war on the
United States Edwin black showed you
some of the key documents which verify
this an IBM shown is much concerned for
American wartime interests as fell
injures critics did for German interests
he would have cut off the indirect
supply to the Nazi war machine of IBM
patented hardware and card where instead
Watson's overriding concern seems to
vent to preserve IBM patents and assets
in order to assure IBM post-war monopoly
profiteering regardless of who won the
war incidentally I served in the
American military government in Germany
from war's end until the late 1948 and
though I was not involved in that aspect
of it I know that American firms were
over there immediately to reclaim their
assets and as somebody has been pointed
out assets that increased considerably
due to the Nazi use of them
when Hitler Unleashed his war of
conquest he was gambling on quick
victories overriding his generals fears
that fears that German resources were
inadequate for a protracted war of
attrition at first Hitler's calculations
seemed accurate but at the end of the
beginning or read the Allied invasion of
North Africa or the beginning of the end
in Churchill's terms Stalingrad his
resources in conquered Europe could only
prolong the war by dint of punch-card
technology during which a major part of
the Second World War as human and
material devastation occurred
on both sides this makes our Edwin
blacks case for IBM in the Nazi war
effort his case for IBM and the
Holocaust is in my opinion more
circumstantial once in power the Nazis
applied the existing and later censuses
the rice genealogical registers and
ezreal hilberg has demonstrated
especially the submissions of the newly
constituted rice Jewish Association to
enforce the Nazis anti-semitic EDA fees
first to implement the Nuremberg racial
laws then to next to coerce Jewish
immigration and to confiscate their
assets and then inexorably to ghettoize
and incarcerate European jewelry on the
way toward mass murder the SS in
particular was already using IBM
designed Hollerith systems for personal
administer Sanel administration payroll
assignments promotions and even edwin
showed you one card even for verifying
the backgrounds the genetic backgrounds
of SS men asking to marry demonstrably
the SS concentration camp administration
used them not only for its staffing of
the camp's but specifically to identify
and reassign individual skilled men
inmates including Jews to alleviate the
escalating manpower shortage before
ultimately working them to death and
Edwin's showed you some of those key
documents but outside Germany Austria
and the Netherlands the data required to
identify and locate Jews was not readily
available for punch card entry the
figures presented to the Von's a
conference on January 1942 were wild
guesstimates drawing on course
submissions by the Jewish councils as
well he'll burgers pointed out for
France the figures were so far off mark
probably because the data
was deliberately withheld by a Vichy
official who eventually paid with his
life for his moral courage and you will
find something of that in Evelyn's book
in fact that's where I learned about it
in Eastern Europe especially Poland the
data on jewelry was amorphous except for
coerced submissions from the Jewish
councils the executor zuv the final
solution
had to resort to physically brutal
roundups mass shootings gas vans and
eventually murder mills conducted by
wastefully inefficient brute force
unaccompanied for the most part by
technological assistance SS personnel
assigned to implement this brute force
constantly whined about the magnitude
and stress of their daunting task as if
they and not their victims deserve pity
so it is scarcely conceivable that they
would have been unaware of or have
neglected to apply the available
technology to facilitate the final
solution where it was at all applicable
nevertheless IBM assistance to the Nazi
war of conquest entrapped the Jews not
only of Germany but of all of Europe
exposing them to the final solution and
enabling it in spite of its considerable
detraction from the main Nazi war effort
that abomination received an uncaring
assist from Thomas Watson and his IBM
not only did his did Watson's
acquisitiveness substantially aid and
prolong the Nazi war effort but
according to the hard circumstantial
evidence documented in coherent context
by Edwin black also enabled the
Holocaust that is Edwin blacks case for
IBM and the Holocaust thank you
okay what we'll do not with the
remaining time we have is that I'm
interested in taking any questions from
anyone about anything any topic you
might want to come up to the microphones
so you can be heard just come on up and
I'll take you one at a time and I hope
everybody SP above all the hard ones
first iBM has refused to respond in in
any substantive way first they said they
had not seen a copy of the book even
though the Madison Street bookshop had
broken the embargo and was sawing it
just on the street from in their world
head headquarters in New York they have
it has now been over a week since the
book has been available they have not
responded by denying or confirming any
of the facts of course they have known
about their activities for 60 years they
have known that 15 million people have
seen the Hollerith machine in the
Holocaust Museum since 1993 articles
have been written in the in journals
from 1995 there were major piece leaks
in community papers in 1980 in 1989 and
1990 1998-99
I personally reviewed my entire outline
with them in 1999 they made copies of
all the documents they transferred out
before they gave them to me and the last
thing they said is that if if any of my
information is verifiable they'll turn
it over to a historian I don't quite
know what that means but what they have
done instead of as a tactic is instead
of answering the questions they've been
able to bamboozle the media into
spending its time addressing everything
but the history it wasn't that this book
was embargoed it was that IBM wanted to
beat the publisher to the punch the
publisher was determined to bring this
out in one intelligent
sensationalized con context without
little bits and pieces dribbling out
there under contract that you could not
use any sensational terms such as untold
secret exclusive for the first time but
IBM in order to divert attention
notified more than 300,000 people and
the entire media the Friday before the
book that the book was coming out and
that it was hooked up to this lawsuit
and successfully bamboozled the media
into talking about that instead of
talking about the facts iBM has declined
every opportunity by every journalistic
organization to address even one fact in
the book that's responsive IBM to date
but I hope that they would simply face
up to what has been done opened their
archives not just to German boxes but
the Swedish boxes the Swiss boxes to
Latin American boxes the French boxes to
Polish boxes and we can find out the
rest of what is behind this tragic story
sir
we know the period before with an
agreement or set of a transcript of a
phone conversation how are those
conversations the conversation um
because they're all oral agreements
usually there's a note or a memo or a
letter saying oh we're not going to have
any written agreement but we have this
oral agreement between us and this has
been conveyed and at various times when
Watson was not living up to his oral
agreement the man and the German
managers would have would object and
would demand some letter or written comp
con-con confirmation of it in the letter
I just showed you it is a resume of a
conversation in which they said we
finally resolved this they were all
agreement that was made was confirmed
and now on September 27th and we can
keep these machines that's how you
document an oral agreement by written
memorandum generally it was a letter
merely saying that the general man but
by the senior people in Germany saying
the general manager of Europe spoke to
Thomas Watson between New York and
Switzerland and he agreed to to to this
procedure if you give me just a second
one of these has a letter in it the
Polish one directly to Thomas Watson
reminding him of his oral agreement and
it says this offer made orally by you
dear mr. Watson and now in a limited
degree accepted by us with this proposal
in a somewhat changed form will
undoubtedly be greatly appreciated in
many and especially responsible circles
and then a few days later there is a
long minutes of a conversation on of the
German staff which was translated in the
New York office where they confirm that
this oral this oral agreement was was
read was re was reconfirmed and it was
communicated yesterday morning mr. shott
telephone once more and informed me
obviously pleased that he had again
spoken with America namely mr. Watson
and mr. Augsburg and after this this
other information had been cleared up
agreement had been expressed to are
keeping machines are asked for until
further notice on the basis of my
proposition in other instances we have a
check we have a check subsidiary that
says that gives an affidavit saying they
were authorized in writing to build the
customers and to accept the money from
the customers but were only authorized
verbally to deposit the money in the
bank one has to wonder why you
authorized your manager to receive to
receive the money but only verbally
authorized them to deposit it in the
bank somewhere in the book there's
extensive discussion about Watson early
on in 1933 gave the German subsidiary
the right to take over all commercial
terror terror territory in Europe and
they said well would this is just oral
green oral agreement and the German
manager demanded a written letter
confirming it and after letters went
back and forth they finally said yes you
have confirmed our oral understanding
oral under stings were very very
commonplace and at one point when the
Justice Department was investigating
Watson's papers in the early 40s it was
explained that mr. Watson preferred
oral agreements and that's why there was
not documentation if I explain it to you
thank you from here my question to you
is well we are very careful to lay out
the long saga of the Holocaust from
persecution to genocide these are
different matters what was going on in
1933 is not what was going on in 1943
and as of October of 1941 just before
the u.s. entered the war
Watson sent a notice out to all the
subsidiaries saying please do not inform
us of what you are doing and do not ask
us any questions or seek our advice so
the only thing we can say is that the
world knew that Jews were being
registered Jews were being rounded up
and Jews were being sent off to to
various forms of demise that's in the
headlines I think that if we're going to
be fair we cannot at any point say that
Watson knew that Jews were being sent to
death to the death camps there's nothing
a documentation that shows that if there
was I would have included it it was
never about the anti-semitism it was
never about to Nazism it was always
about the money well it's not quite as
simple as that but there was a long
years long operation of ancestral and
genealogical tracing everyone in that
part of in in German influenced or
occupied land was subject to ancestral
pedigree including all the audience I
think that Nils is one of the people
here who found some of the remote
counties in the area who had been able
to identify not only a Jew but a half
Jew and a quarter Jew in 1/16 Jew and
they knew exactly who these Jews were
and they were under observation one
needs to understand that these machines
were not like Palm Pilots they didn't
carry them around what was important is
that everybody was keeping Trek from
church records to social records to
organizational records there were just
pieces of paper but the pieces of paper
were sent into statistical offices and
other places where they could be punched
up
where he was from my mother what she did
where she was from you have to wait to
chapter 15 to find out the answer next
for many years I repeatedly whenever I
grant across the Nazi investigation and
we queried various federal agencies we
told the documents with classified
immunities ran up against us of the
state department at justice at the CIA
and a number of others lately I have
been following this for a long time and
I've noticed when I read Richard Wright
Facebook official statements about
border police he notes in his research
notes that all consular traffic from
1933 to 1939 American consulates in
Europe remain classified as the date of
the writing of his book I wanted to ask
you in light of what you just said about
opening up the Swedish box wrench box 77
how much if you encountered this this
type of situation
are there to your knowledge substantial
blocks of information that are in the
archives that have yet to be
declassified yet to be made available to
historians and our hidden still from the
public well I very much appreciate your
questions and you again in your name sir
let me try to respond and say in
addition to the fact that 90 to 95
percent of the documents that I look
forward to National Archives that were
listed were missing most of them were
also classified now they were routinely
Declassified but in some cases I found
documents as late as 1972 which had been
pulled by British intelligence I had to
have them specially Declassified or
request that they be declassified I
would say that there are thousands of
documents which are still classified at
the National Archives which have yet to
be discovered and or ones which have
just been neglected but I think that
you're going to find a very hard road in
front of you if you're going to go after
these documents
I certainly had a hard road and in more
than the National Archives we found that
many of these documents were simply gone
when you run up against a final trick
wall get the dumb piece of nothing boom
if they're still there and they simply
say sorry you can't get it if I find
this one it's a thousand dollars to your
favorite charity all right thank you
very much if there's I'll take one more
question we bet done one more yes ma'am
yeah I'll tell you what we went into
sterilization and I did extensive work
on sterilization and I found that the
IBM system was used to identify those
who were involved in sterilization there
was actually a ad in the IBM publication
of how simple papers were filled out in
the doctor's office and used processed
some twenty four times to I do I
identify the medical defects for people
to be sterilized I looked very hard and
everybody wanted me to find it to go the
next step to youth to euthanasia however
I could not find the documentation to
support IBM's involvement in euthanasia
try as I as hard as I did I know my
colleagues is sitting here we looked
hard but we found that euthanasia and I
consulted with Henry Friedlander and
others was basically based on an
arbitrary determination of simple bits
of paper so I tried couldn't find it no
no no euthanasia I think would that be
the last one just one just one oh did
you ever
not to leave one question that came here
about why records are still there all
these years most of and there's no need
to undertake that enterprise the Nazi
war crimes Disclosure Act which was
passed the year or two ago is designed
to take out of the agency's records that
are classified that have any relation to
war crimes particularly the Nazi who are
crimes with also now the Japanese and so
that's been going on for a year I'm now
involved in it officially and it is what
we're finding is that the agencies are
still reluctant to turn things over but
it's going to happen the reason why
things of states classified so long is
basically because intelligence agencies
operating on these understandable
exception and anything that comes from a
foreign source and the foreign source
wants it to remain classified if we
start revealing it then those sources
will close up and so that's been the
rationale for most of the
declassification thank you thanks for
change I one quick minute and then we've
got to wrap it up go ahead pump it
shorts ask me about the media circus
about the media circus okay
the details secondly what the book have
been less controversial infinite
entitled and I haven't read yet IBM and
support of Nazi Germany as opposed to
IBM home ok first of all with regard to
the lawsuit anytime there revelations
like this there's going to be a rush to
to the courthouse and so there were
about a thousand copies of my manuscript
running around I was in consultation
with at least six of six attorneys
couple of prosecutors I'm sure you know
who some of the P who some of those
prosecutors are money laundering experts
thirty-five historians contrary to what
Michael Dobbs wrote in The Washington
Post that the book was not reviewed by
historians this book was viewed by more
historians than almost any book in
recent memory usually a book of this
nature is reviewed by some four or five
in my case was thirty five historians of
all Nietzsche's and specialties and this
list was made available to the
Washington Post and we're very confused
as to why they did not run that so there
was this lawsuit but I really wish the
lawsuit would all these suits that are
being discussed now would sort of
disappear because they are detracting
from the discussion of the book itself
and that's actually good for IBM because
IBM doesn't want us to actually talk
about the history they want people to
talk about the lawsuits and about the
media now I asked to the proper title of
this book I thought many times about
calling it IBM and world war two I
thought many times about calling it IBM
and Nazi Europe or Nazi Germany I called
it IBM in the Holocaust because I'm a
Jew and I'm investigating not the
conflict of Marshall forces but the
destruction of six million Jews and how
these factors intersected during that
time there have been so many war books
written my book was IBM in the hole
cost it was the most honest book the
most honest title the proper title and
my publishers were good enough to allow
me to take the wide view with the
economic with the technologic with the
diplomatic and with the military all in
one to show that enabled and strong and
recovered Nazi Europe as my friend Bob
wolf knows was capable of undertaking a
vast destruction of Jewish people as its
highest in parent imperative thank you
very much
it's hard to express the gratitude of of
the Jewish community let alone of this
audience of all people of good faith in
good conscience to you Edwin black and
to you mr. seltzer and to you dr. wolf
not only for your contribution to this
particular book but to your contribution
to the seemingly endless task of seeking
the truth about of extraordinary evil I
thank you the audience who has come this
evening on very short notice to express
your appreciation to this author to
these scholars and to the many others
who have worked to uncover this chapter
of history I'd like to invite you please
to join us in the lobby for a light
reception where you may greet mr. black
mr. seltzer and mist and dr. wolf as I
mentioned earlier copies of the book are
available and mr. black has graciously
consented to sign thank you thank you to
Michael Hartman for interpreting and
thank you to c-span for covering our
program this evening